andrea vous êtes vous avez fait le grand
écart cette partie de la france a
soumises parti pour lequel vous avez
milité pendant onze ans pour rejoindre
le rassemblement national et marine le
pen alors envie de savoir pourquoi est
ce que c'est un coup de coeur pour
marine le pen ou est ce que c'est un
coup de coeur pour l'assemblement
nationale ou bien ce que c'est un
désamour pour la france insoumise mais
d'abord il sait plusieurs choses d'abord
la france soumise à changer complètement
de cap s'est soumise à des idéologies
racialiste islamophobe et on en reparle
à tout à l'heure mais pour le reste je
crois que le clivage gauche droite
n'existe plus 70% des français
aujourd'hui ne s'identifie plus ni de
gauche ni de droite aujourd'hui on a un
nouveau clivage qui est le camp
populaire face au camp des élites le
localisme faso globalisme ceux qui
croient encore en la france dans le
génie français dans la création
d'emplois sur notre sol dans
l'émancipation des jeunes dans les
nouvelles perspectives c'est ce que
propose marine le pen et contrairement à
ce que dit notre ami porte-parole de
madame pécresse il dit que
marine le pen a changé non vous savez
quand vous passez 12 ans avec jean luc
mélenchon c'est la constance de marine
le pen qui a fait en sorte que j'ai pris
confiance en elle quand marine le pen
défend la justice sociale quand marine
le pen défend la laïcité et comment il
veut tout à l'heure ça séparés parce que
vous êtes vous avez gagné contre un élu
et rennes n'ont enfin pas ce que tu dis
est élu contre le fn il doit
démissionner
j'ai vu tout à l'heure les personnages
que vous avez pas identiques sont partis
de chez marine le pen vers eric zemmour
ouais y en ad'autres notre parti et
madame lienemann du ps verts
mélenchon aucun d'entre eux n'a
démissionné de son mandat il a dit que
vous étiez vous allez il a dit pour
solde de tout compte qu tarak est le nom
d'une boule puante de fin de campagne un
coup monté le soutien d'un tel traitera
ses amis déshonorent ceux qui compterait
pour en profiter qu'ils respecteront les
électeurs élus contre le fn le fn il
doit démissionner de son mandat je vais
vous répondre sur deux choses d'abord
jean luc mélenchon n'a pas écouté
puisque j'ai démissionné avant sont
cuites çà et je suis le seul d'ailleurs
à avoir démissionné parce que c'est bien
beau de
c'est bien beau
de dire qu'il ya l'abstention à chaque
fois qu'on a les soirées électorales que
les français n'ont pas voté mais on a
des gens tous bords ceux qui sont partis
chez zemmour ceux qui sont partis
d'ailleurs chez mélenchon du parti
socialiste aucun d'entre eux n'a
démissionné son mandat aucun d'entre eux
n'a respecté les électeurs qui les ont
élus moi je les ai respectées j'ai mis
mes un denim des deux côtés et je suis
les marines la rai le panneau je suis
témoin de cela il est un des seuls le
seul même peut-être qui a démissionné de
son mandat parce que ils changeaient de
mouvements politiques pour restituer aux
électeurs qui ont voté quand même un
représentant non mais des vendeurs dix
jours sur l'immigration par exemple
cessé la la c'est le grand écart mais la
france a soumises et ils rassemblement
national pas du tout moi je vais vous
dire moi j'ai je suis le fils de deux
parents qui viennent d'ailleurs mais moi
ils m'ont élevée dans l'amour de la
france et m'ont toujours dit qu'il faut
rendre à la france ce qu'elle nous a
donné c'est ce que je fais ici avec
marine le pen je veux sauver la france
des mondialistes de ceux qui nous ont
gouvernés jusqu'à maintenant mais je
vais revenir au tweet de jean luc
mélenchon qui dit que c'est un trets et
moi quand je suis parti de la france
soumise avait deux conditions 1
démissionné de mon mandat est de ne pas
attaquer personnellement jean luc
mélenchon même ceux qui sont partis
attaque marine le pen moi jamais par
contre je vais l'attaquer sur le fond
pour moi ceux qui ont trahi complètement
leurs idéaux c'est la france est soumise
marine le pen par led et indigéniste
vous savez madame bouteldja que vous
connais qui dit que les juifs se
reconnaît à se fondre a blanchi t elle a
été condamnée elle me dit que les blancs
sont ravis de voir que des homosexuels
indigènes font leur coming out parce que
le blanc et homophobe etc etc ces gens
qui ont une vision racialiste vous savez
jean luc mélenchon les avait condamnés
ils avaient pris des distances avec en
2017 il avait dit que c'était une
association raciste antisémite qu'est-ce
que vous avez remarqué en février 2021
c'est que le qg le média qg le média des
indigéniste de madame bouteldja soutient
aujourd'hui officiellement jean luc
mélenchon c'est moi qui ai changé ou
c'est jean luc mélenchon c'est jean luc
mélenchon quand vous avez monsieur pena
ruiz qui est un philosophe qui a défendu
la laïcité dont jean luc mélenchon
lui-même disait que c'était son maître à
penser en 2008 en 2019 ils l'ont chassé
de la france soumise il a même été
menacé physiquement qu'est ce que c'est
moi qui ai changé c'est jean-luc qu'est
ce que c'est j'avançais série voilà
on en a parlé d'ailleurs jean-luc
mélenchon est nu dans mon émission où on
a parlé de ses positions notamment de
ses sorties contre contre le crif etc
c'est ça qui vous a dérangé aussi moi ce
qui me dérange c'est prenez le cas de
l'islamophobie tout à l'heure on en
parle moi je réfute ce terme comme jean
luc mélenchon de pendant des années je
refuse et je n'accepte pas que on
attaque des croyants musulmans ou des
croyants chrétiens c'est pas ça dont je
parle mais en france avait emmené dans
une république laïque où on a droit de
croire ou de ne pas croire on a le droit
de critiquer une religion de la carie q4
caricaturer on a droit d'avoir peur dans
les religions un anarchiste a peur dans
les religions on peut être mélenchon lui
même en 2015 dit qu'on a droit d'être
islamophobe christianophobes parce que
c'est la liberté dans notre pays quatre
ans plus tard jean luc mélenchon
défilent dans une marche contre
l'islamophobie avec le ccf et un tas
d'autres organisations dissoute depuis
parce que dangereuse et islamistes sous
les cris d' allah wa gloire à 300 mètres
du bataclan c'est moi qui ai changé ou
c'est la france soumise bien évidemment
que celle à froid sont soumises mais
sione pourquoi il a changé à votre avis
jean luc mélenchon écoutez moi j'ai
appris mais bon qui est des sondages
internes chez eux qui vont chercher un
électorat tout simplement mais au delà
de de la france soumise là parce que je
parle à 300 soumises qui ne plus
républicaine qui n'est plus
laïque je dirais mais par contre je
parle à toute la gauche la gauche a
perdu même le combat social vous avez vu
monsieur jadot tout à l'heure sur le
carburant en 2013 marine l'a dit il
voulait une augmentation 18 centimes de
carburant donc ils n'ont pas idée de
comment les gens s'offre au regard des
madame sandrine rousseau en oui on vous
explique que vu l'augmentation du gaz de
l'énergie il faut mettre un pull et
baissé de 2 degrés son chauffage mais
monsieur hanouna ya 12 millions de
français qui n'arrivent pas à chauffer
aujourd'hui 1 aura 24 millions de son
prochain cette gauche et yannick jadot
volonté des mecs jadot voulait augmenter
le carburant s'ils s'associent avec anne
hidalgo là avec les embouteillages ne
faisant pas
là on est mort
non je vous rassure parce qu'ils sont
pour interdire en réalité des voitures
qui ont un certain âge d'entrer dans les
grandes villes donc les vols les gens
qui ont des voitures restantes auront le
droit d'aller dans les centres villes
mais les gens qui n'ont pas les moyens
de s'acheter une nouvelle voiture parce
qu'ils ont plus le droit
alors que l'appareil s'est meurent pour
agir et andrea juste la question que
tout le monde se pose c'est d'accord on
comprends votre position peut la
comprendre sur la france a soumis mais
pourquoi maintenant avoir rejoint marine
le pen et le rassemblement national bat
comme je vous le disais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le clivage politique est
d'ailleurs que je pense comme 70% des
français puisqu'il est un sondage ce
n'est plus la gauche contre la droite
vous avez vu mais qu'est ce qui vous a
plu mais qu'est ce qui m'a plu c'est sa
constance savez on nous explique ago là
j'ai rencontré comment s'est passée bas
ou si vous voulez moi ça s'est passé
assez simplement c'est que j'ai eu mon
constat je suis convaincu que marine le
pen et républicaine laïque je la vois
dans les combats je la vois face à
monsieur messier a qui proposent la
reconquête mais le ventre vide puisque
le pouvoir d'achat ces accessoires donc
j'ai vu cette constance chez marine le
pen après humainement parlant je veux
pas vous mentir une fois ce constat fait
une fois que vous êtes convaincus par
marine le pen c'est un peu comme un saut
à l'élastique vous savez pas si
l'élastique est attaché à ce que vous
connaissez pas les gens du rassemblement
national vous connaissez pas ce monde là
eh bien je dois venir quand vous venez
de la transaction mis en exergue des
homos regarder henry bech 2,6 à rien
c'est que j'ai vu une bienveillance
assez extraordinaire on va ressembler
mois en france a soumis à la france à
redon que vous n'avez pas vue à la
française c'est à dire que la france
soumise j'ai passé 12 années à défendre
le peuple français celui qui souffrait
de la précarité énergétique des jeunes
qui n'arrivait pas à se loger des
français qui n'arrivait pas à défendre
leurs emplois y compris des seniors
j'entends tout à l'heure monsieur le
partant alain pécresse qui disent c'est
66 derrière présente sept ans mais à 50
ans on a trois millions de français qui
n'a qui sont déjà au chômage qui sont
licenciées parce que considéré comme
trop bu donc c'est ça qui m'a plu et
puis marine le pen m'a dit bon que tara
qui va falloir bosser chez nous et j'ai
appris j'ai vu un parti on a bossé
franchement le concept de des
métropolisation c'est nous qui l'avons
décidé c'est un organisme de localisme
d'ailleurs j'étais en charge avec le
brand hervé jeu du localisme et vous
voyez on a réussi cette bataille qualité
en parlais tout à l'heure avec marine le
pen justement de ceux qui ont quitté
marine le pen pour aller chez eric
zemmour on parlait de carriéristes vous
c'est
quand on parle de carrière est ce que
vous dites parce que je croyais plus en
marine le pen un moment où jean luc
mélenchon il était en difficulté là il
remonte toujours en effet tout le monde
est petit trot monté à la fin mai ils
étaient ils étaient en énorme difficulté
il ya ya ya trois quatre mois c'est pour
ça pas vous avez pardon mélanger mois il
lui les annonceurs mais bon c'est
l'argent il ya eu toutes ces histoires
voilà avant et toutes ces histoires moi
c'est le fond politique c'est pas les
histoires de jean-luc mélenchon pour moi
il est toujours en indélicatesse
toujours faible au niveau républicain
quand je vois que les uns des génisses
le soutiennent pour moi il n'est pas en
position de force d'avoir des anti
républicain aujourd'hui qui le
soutiennent pour le reste je suis
heureux d'avoir une candidate qui je
lisais tout à leur travail avant des
concepts le localisme la des métropoles
isation et j'ai vu et c'est là que ça me
fait plaisir on découvre que la bataille
des idées étaient gagnés sur le
localisme donc j'étais en charge quand
je vois aux élections régionales qu'une
najat vallaud belkacem ancien ministre
socialiste prononce le mot localistes
mais j'ai rigolé ça m'a souri ça m'a
fait plaisir quand votre programme
devient le supermarché de vos
concurrents qui sont créés niasse vous
savez gagner la bataille en plus ils
payent pas inné vol les idées si vous
voulez la bataille des idées et gagner à
les gagner quant à eux cassen parts de
localisme quand on parle de dé
métropolisation comme monsieur jadot
nous parle de de localisme tenir leur de
local vous à vous aviez des potes à la
france insoumis qu'est ce que vous dites
que bon je vois toujours évidemment dire
vous voir comme le diable d un certain
me pensent comme les diables puis
d'autres
ont des liens humains avec moi ce qui
est normal quand vous passez de douze
années dans une structure mais je vais
taire leur nom parce que bien évidemment
c'est mal vu pour eux aujourd'hui de
pouvoir parler avec moi mais moi je
lance un appel à tous et toutes ces
personnes de gauche qui sont abandonnés
par une hidalgo un jadot qui ont
abandonné le combat social abandonné
malheureusement par un jean luc
mélenchon sur les questions de
république de laïcité d'unités de la
nation pour combat tous ces concepts
racialiste qui divisent les français et
c'est le rassemblement l'indivisibilité
de la république l'une des deux nations
qui m'a plu chez marine le pen et je
suis fier de la soutenir avec toutes les
personnes qui version
[Applaudissements]